she is a first type amen person yeah 100
percent
[Music]
hey it's Josh Potter and I'm back to
answer the internet would you watch a
sex tape of your number one celebrity
banging your arch enemy hell yeah that
would be so fun I don't care who it is
in the sex tape I watch everyone's sex
tape I don't care if it's two two hobos
did you if you said you had two hobos on
a sex tape I go let me check that out
would you watch your mother's sex tape
I mean I wouldn't want to but if you
were like she a celebrity I'd be
like all right I Gotta See would you
watch the tape of your own conception
knowing that it's the load that led to
you does that make it even weirder like
when he's like oh you go there's me
that's crazy yeah would you switch lives
with Tim Tebow if you still had to
follow his rules about booze sex and
going to church no Tim Tebow this looks
like that's like prison I mean he's
so famous I hear Tim Tebow likes
his blowies though and he's allowed to
yes he's he's like married now right no
I mean back in college days David Nelson
says he he says I go did he ever I asked
David Nelson did Tim Tebow ever and
he goes I can't verify that but I know
he likes his blowies
that's like you know the loophole yeah
it's like butt sex I'm sure he did butt
sex right Tim Tebow no I couldn't do it
I would if I'm Tim Tebow I'm off the
rails I'm like I'm me I'm I mean there's
no chance who could you handle more Tim
Tebow's life as like a sober Luther dork
or Russell Wilson just being like my
whole personality as a door I can't tell
if Russell Wilson like when Gets behind
closed doors if he's like give me a beer
or something you know what I'm saying
like you know I don't know what he duck
he is so weird I think like we
have to have a mental health discussion
about Russell Wilson he should come out
and say that he does before it gets too
crazy and then he could be like this
advocate for you know mental health and
all that stuff because it's getting
weird
would you rather everyone in your
girlfriend's office want to her or
nobody want to her I get I like I
like not jealousy but I do like knowing
that I'm with a desirable woman is
exciting to me so I would like that I
mean as long as she's not actually
the people in the office it's
kind of fun to know that all these dudes
wanna her you know it makes me feel
more normal would you rather wear high
heels or a belly shirt I would so much
rather wear high heels if it's gonna
hurt my feet it's gonna suck but also
your calves are gonna get yoked
and the belly shirt is just I don't have
the best belly if I was like a little
more washboardy I would go belly shirt
yeah plus it's cold and I'm hairy and
like I know it's we're talking like
physical Comfort here yeah with the
shoes but also I I I think of it as like
man I'm gonna get my calves
going after a while you get used to it
you call us up it's like hiking do you
think you could throw a football farther
than a 1940s Heisman winner I don't
think I could but I bet you're the
average guy could you know what I mean
me I'm a little bit less than the
average guy I mean I'm not athletic in
any way shape or form I think if you
took me back to the 40s I'd still get
like cut from the you know
I tried to throw a ball one time and uh
Bert Kreischer made fun of me so hard oh
no it was that tennis match that they
did and I was like here you go Bert ah
and he's like do you know how to
throw a ball I'm like I guess I don't
how old is too old to watch cartoons
interesting I
detest cartoons I've never watched The
Simpsons I never watched Family Guy I
see you being like let's get high and
just watch no I'm not that high energy
I'm like let's get high and watch like a
nature documentary or something it's not
really I don't like Adult Swim I I don't
think there's a too old but there there
is like some weird like adult person who
gets like stuck into that do you know
what I'm saying and then they're wearing
like a weird hat like with ears on like
there's a girl that I'm seeing vividly
in my life yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that kind of gets a little
creepy to me Bob's Burgers or something
that even that I go all right grow up
like 13 I don't know and that's a crazy
answer probably would you count to one
million for one million dollars you are
locked in an empty room until you're
finished yeah but like if you mess up
you gotta start over oh my God I
probably I would do it to try and get
the million dollars but I would die from
Insanity I would keep up and I
would just be stuck in I would be in
that room for the rest of my life Mary
kill Lisa Turtle Kelly Kapowski
Jesse Spano love this question I think I
would marry Kelly I would love to
Lisa she's nuts and I would kill Jesse
because she was obnoxious and like such
a nerd unless you're a
full-blown racist you're killing Justin
right if you're a racist you're killing
uh Lisa also if you're a masochist
you're probably like marrying Jessie
like you just love abuse you're like oh
yeah like yell at me Mama here's the
thing though Lisa is very very high
maintenance remember she was like
shopping all the time and there was a
lot that's a definite like one night
because like you can't have your whole
life be like that Kelly Kapowski was
simple she was just like I like flowers
or whatever you know what I mean like
she's one of those girls you could
really just like make happy with the
smallest okay hottest version of Kelly
Kapowski Bayside cheerleader lifeguard
during the summer college Years and when
then she did that other show I mean I
think she was like the classic and I
think the rest of them got hotter as
time went on you know but she was like
out of the gate hot yeah I didn't know
that I wasn't gay yes she is a first
boner type amen person yeah 100 first
daughter
thank you for watching answer the
internet please subscribe to the channel
comment below on other celebrities you'd
like to see and make sure you hit the
Bell to get notifications when new
episodes come out